the murder of george floyd by a
policeman
sparked the biggest civil rights
protests in america's history
millions took to the streets to denounce
racism and police brutality
the movement resonated around the world
a year later some progress has been made
in america
police reform legislation is spreading
across the country
and the officer responsible for floyd's
death is in jail
but the pandemic has exposed how racism
can literally be
a matter of life or death in america
black people are almost twice as likely
to die from covert 19 as white people
black patients were turned away because
they seemed like they were
well oxygenated when in fact they were
actually quite ill
a year after george floyd's murder
economist journalists
spoke to subscribers about how the
pandemic has illuminated the systemic
racism in america
covert 19 has killed african-americans
at higher rates right so somebody
looking
that that might say well that's that's
racism but if so kind of
how is it racism how does that operate
what kovitch showed us
is that the existing disparities
like lack of access to quality health
care lack of access
to pharmacies lack of access to good
jobs um
good primary care physicians health
insurance
can have huge impacts um beyond
just that immediate thing right it's not
just that grandma can't get her for her
medication it's not just that
you know you don't have a doctor that
you like though those are all really
important
but when it comes down to a pandemic but
it comes down to
public health of everyone these
disparities have an
impact that impacts those communities
but also others
um so i think that kova did a really
did while it's devastating
it did a good job of illuminating
how impactful these racial disparities
are
both for the communities that are
directly impacted like black americans
hispanic americans native americans etc
but also how it impacts others who might
otherwise not have been aware of those
disparities
i think one of the interesting things
here to maybe highlight is often those
disparities are
not caused because somebody somewhere
in particular is acting in bad faith
right you had an
interesting piece for the science uh
section of the economist recently
about pulse oximeters those devices that
we've all become quite
um familiar with that measure blood
oxygen levels and
and you know pretty useful when working
out
um whether somebody who has covered 19
is sick enough to need to go to
the er or or a e as brits would call it
the emergency room
can you talk a little bit about that
usually when we think about racism
um particularly in america we think
about it individually right we think of
this individual person is racist and
they do something
that um is bad right they they
discriminate they
yell they refuse service but
what we're seeing um in the past few
years especially with george floyd's
murder
is this acknowledgement of the
structural aspects of racism
and one of the things that that makes
that really clear
is the story as you mentioned of the
pulse oximeter so
the pulsar exhibitor many of you have
probably experienced that um
it it's something that goes right onto
the end of your finger when you go to
the hospital or to the doctor
and essentially it looks at your pulse
but also your
oxygen levels and it's used to determine
if somebody
is um has low oxygen and is ill and when
we had
at the pika pandemic a need to triage
patients
uh many people were sent home if it
seemed like their oxygen levels were
actually
um high enough that they were likely not
in trouble they could go home
um and and wait it out
and maybe get better or return when they
were getting worse um
some people were even given these pulse
examiners at home to monitor
unfortunately what we're finding that
the way the pulse oximeter works
was actually causing black people or
darker skinned people to look like they
had
higher oxygen levels than they actually
did so it works by passing light through
the finger
um and or other parts of your body like
maybe your earlobe
and when you pass light through your
finger clearly what comes
what it goes through is your skin and
the darker pigmented uh skin
was uh responding differently than
lighter pigmented skin and since it was
calibrated against white skin the
researchers were likely white
the test subjects were predominantly
white
um it being calibrated against white
skin meant it was more accurate against
white skin
so what ended up happening and it's
possible that happened is that
black patients were turned away because
they seemed like they were
well oxygenated when in fact they were
actually quite ill so this is a great
example
there was not a as far as we know there
was a nurse wasn't looking at somebody
and said oh
you're black you don't need help when
they're you know or even more implicitly
they weren't thinking necessarily that
this person doesn't need help though we
do know that those types of biases exist
in medicine what was likely happening is
what seemed like
it was something that was objective
which is an objective medical device
but because this device was developed on
white americans or lighter skinned
people
it had this horrible impact of
improperly
um measuring on darker-skinned people
so i think that's a really great example
of how you know this focus on individual
racism is important and we should all
think deeply about the biases we carry
but we must also acknowledge
the structural ways that racism can
creep in
um even if it's just something as simple
as not testing enough black people
when you're piloting a device john we
were talking about this idea
of structural racism i put you on the
spot and asked you to define it
and because you're very quick on your
feet or have thought about this a lot
before
or maybe both you said that one
useful way of thinking about it is
racism without
racists and what tamara's just described
with the pulse oximeter seems like
a a good example of that and b um
also an example of kind of quite how
hard
it's going to be to close
some of these disparities i mean in some
sense it it
might be easier to
reduce racial disparities in america if
they were caused by
a group of kind of bad people going
around now
sort of doing unhelpful things but by
and large
i think most of the disparities that
we're worried about and that everyone
wants to close
are not primarily caused by that and
kovitz seems like
you know the covet health disparities
seem like a good illustration of that
i think that's one thing that makes it
so difficult right it's
it's it's easy to believe in a story
with obvious villains
who are people who you can vanquish in
this case we're talking about
structures and practices you know let's
say for the sake of argument
usually engaged in by well-intentioned
people
but who consequently need to reflect on
what they do and how they do it this is
something i i wrote about in my
in my book when i wrote about facial
recognition systems
because they were by and large developed
by white men and often tested on
primarily
you know subjects with lighter skin they
don't perform well on subjects with
with with darker skin in america that
has led to mistaken arrests of innocent
african-americans because the facial
recognition programs did not recognize
them well
so there are when you talk about
structural racism there there are sort
of two sets of questions the first is
what are the structures that led us to
this position whether it's
how we test a pulse oximeter or how we
test a facial recognition algorithm
the more important question then becomes
what are you going to do about it
so it's it's it's one thing to say that
that structural racism
is racism without racists without
overtly
discriminating without people who
discriminate overtly but then once you
have determined
that this pattern of racial bias exists
what do you do about it that is often a
much harder question to answer much
harder for a lot of people
because it you know forces people to
confront the ways in which
they in which we have been perpetuating
racial bias
without intending to so you have to be
really reflective in how you approach
question of structural racism
and uh it's very hard to do that without
getting defensive at some point but that
is a that is a stage that that
people have to work through if they want
to promote better outcomes for everyone
i'm john pritto the u.s editor at the
economist i've written a special report
about race in america which you can read
by clicking on this link
don't forget to subscribe to our youtube
channel and thanks for watching